or the West African block ecowas has
directed the activation of a standby
Force to restore democracy in Niger
following the coup the leaders have
concluded their emergency meeting in
Abuja they have condemned the Detention
of presidents Muhammad bazoom and say
the regional block will enforce strict
travel restrictions to Niger and freeze
assets of individuals in the way of a
return to a civilian government
direct the committee of the chief of
Defense staff
to activate the aqua standby force with
all its elements immediately
order the deployment
of the ecowas standby Force
to restore constitutional order in the
Republic of Niger
underscore its continued commitment
to the restoration of constitutional
order through peaceful means
okay let's get more on this with Ahmad
Idris who's in Abuja Nigeria where that
ecowas Summit has just finished and I
mean first of all can you just tell us a
little bit more about the standby
military force what is it exactly entail
just how large is it
well they're not talking specifically in
terms of numbers but this is a force
that has been agreed upon by member
states uh the last time it was deployed
was to guinea bissau to stabilize the
political situation that following a
core attempt so the numbers can range
between three thousand to six thousand
or even more depending on the
circumstances and this comprises mainly
of the military the police and even
civil components of that standby Force
they are armed and also they are also
empowered to carry out other Civic
duties uh in areas where they are
deployed so the deployment of this Force
probably could signal the start of
something big like a military
intervention in Niger
okay is this actually going to work do
you think I mean we're looking at strict
travel restrictions to Nigeria freeze on
assets for individuals in a bid to try
and return the civilian government is
any of this actually going to work
it all depends on the uh will willpower
of the leaders of the economic community
of West African States yes Nigeria has
the number and it's expected to be the
largest contributor and with uh
countries like the United States France
and others solidly behind Echoes we
probably are seeing the possibility of
financial help from these organizations
the countries may have uh the Nigeria
and its and member states of Echoes may
have uh the numbers may have the troops
but the financial requirements or the
logistics required for this will have to
come from external forces as well
because at the moment we're looking at
countries that are struggling with their
economies right now and also dealing
with their own domestic problems okay
thank you so much for that that's
armored address for us in Abuja Nigeria
where the ecowas summit has just
concluded
Arabi has more from niger's capital on
the coup leaders action just ahead of
the Eco wild Summit
the military Genta has just named a new
government directed by laminzane who is
also Minister of Finance the government
is composed by 21 members including 15
civil members and six military members
the nomination of the government can be
seen as a direct answer to ecowas
emergency meeting in Abuja
it shows also that the military Genta
doesn't care about ecowas declarations
and will continue to ignore any
international calls touring States He
also presidents thou said president who
is under house arrest says that he is
living in the very hard conditions
without electricity medicine or food
cool leaders have also accused French
forces for fearing captured terrorists
in order to destabilize nature